we have the equation negative 5x plus 4y
is equal to 20 and we're told to find
the intercepts of this equation so we
have to find the intercepts intercepts
and then use the intercepts to graph to
graph this line on the coordinate plane
so then graph graph the line so whenever
someone talks about intercepts they're
talking about where you're intersecting
the x and the y axes so let me label my
axes here so this is the x axis and that
is the y axis there and when I intersect
the x axis what's going on what is my Y
value when I'm at the x axis
well my Y value is 0 I'm not above or
below the x axis so the X X let me write
this down the x intercept the x
intercept the x intercept is when y is
equal to 0 right and then by that same
argument what's the y-intercept
y-intercept
what is the y intercept well if I'm
somewhere along the y axis what's my x
value well I'm not to the right or the
left so my x value has to be 0 so the y
intercept occurs when X is equal to 0 so
to figure out the intercepts let's set y
equal to 0 in this equation and solve
for X and then let's set X is equal to 0
and then solve for y so when y is equal
to 0 what does this equation become I'll
do it in orange you get negative 5x plus
4y
well we're saying Y is 0 so 4 times 0 is
equal to 20
4 times 0 is just 0 so we can just not
write that so let me just rewrite it so
we have negative 5x is equal to 20 we
can divide both sides of this equation
by negative 5 by negative 5 the negative
5s cancel out that was the whole point
behind dividing by negative 5 and we get
X is equal to 20 divided by negative 5
is negative 4 so when y is equal to 0 so
when y is equal to 0 we saw that right
there
X is equal to negative 4 or if we wanted
to plot that point we always put the
x-coordinate for it first so that would
be the point negative 4 comma 0 so let
me graph that so if we go 1 2 3 4 that's
negative 4 and then the y-value is just
0 so that the point is right over there
that is the x-intercept y is 0 X is
negative 4
notice we're intersecting the x-axis now
let's do the exact same thing for the
y-intercept let's set X equal to 0 so if
we set X is equal to 0 we have negative
5 times 0 plus 4 y is equal to 20 well
anything times 0 is 0 so you can just
put that out of the way and this
remember this was setting X is equal to
0 we're doing the y-intercept now so
this just simplifies to 4 y is equal to
20 we can divide both sides of this
equation by 4
to get rid of this 4 right there and you
get Y is equal to 20 over 4 which is 5
so when X is equal to 0 Y is equal to 5
so the point 0 5 is on the graph for the
for this line so 0 5 0 x is 0 and Y is 1
2 3 4 5 right over there and notice when
X is 0 we're right on the y-axis this is
our y-intercept right over there and if
we graph the line all you need is two
points to graph any line so we just have
to connect the dots and that is our line
so let me connect the dots try my best
to draw as straight of a line as I can
well that I can do a better job than
that to draw as straight of a line as I
can and that's the that's the the graph
of this equation using the x intercept
and the y intercept